attention gentlemen I'm agent Carter I
supervised all operations for this
division must be the accent Queen
Victoria thought I was signing up for
the US Army what's your name soldier
Gilmore hye-jin there just be step
forward Hodge but your right foot
forward hmm
cuz I got a few moves I know you'll like
it garnet Phillips I can see that you
are breaking into candidates that's good
get your ass up out of that dirt and
stand on that line of attention till
somebody comes tells you what to do yes
sir General Patton has said wars are
fought with weapons but they are won by
men we are going to win this war because
we have the best men and because they
are gonna get better much better the
strategic scientific reserve
it's an allied effort made up the best
minds in the free world our goal is to
create the best army in this [ __ ] every
army starts with one man
[Music]
again this week we will choose that man
to be the first in a new breed of
super-soldier
[Music]
Roger get that rifle out of the mud
ma will personally escort Adolf Hitler
through the gates of hell
[Applause]
[Music]
that flag means you're only at the
halfway point first man that bring it to
me gets a ride back with agent Connor
let's go get bang the formation Rogers I
said fall in
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
you
you